so there's this great line about music
that says that music is proof that the
human race is greater than it knows
you're not feeling when you hear us
transcendent Symphony you get the
goosebumps and you move to tears or
suppose that cognitive emotional ecstasy
its musics capacity to communicate
the inexpressible it's this urge to
language that human beings have and when
four words don't work we have to
translate it into symphony and these
temporary ecstasy's that we instrument
into existence need to be recorded and
our innovations with recording music or
even more transcendent
what started as a teaching grooves on an
LP patterning the sound instantiating it
into physical form so that it could be
playback has evolved now into a world of
binary digital information ecstasy's
beamed from brain to brain from
someone's heart to someone else's this
is music and indeed that line is spot on
proof human race is greater than it
knows
you